Oh welcome to our final class and I
promised that I'd speak today about
final truths and this was to try to to
to end on a note of on a note of honesty
and truth after all the errors have been
making all quarter and that I guess we
spoke I wasn't Nils that said that the
one of the graded one of the great
techniques of technical exposition is to
tell lies at first and then two and then
once a person understands the simple
thing which isn't quite true then you
then you go into the exceptions which
make it true and well this quarter I've
been getting I've been getting notes
from people who have been looking over
our handouts and I haven't had a chance
to to speak themselves and I'm not sure
I represent their point of view
perfectly but I think it will at least
provide a counterbalance to what I've
been saying and I'm really glad to see
that Paul is back with us today too so
that he can not get his last word in
wherever we are now I hope so one of the
things Paul emphasized the great
advantage on Wednesday with the
importance of organization and I feel
here a little guilty that I haven't got
a great organization today I'm going to
go through my nice my scheme is going to
be to go through these notes that I've
received and put them into a bit of
order only first of all like I got
several comments from Nancy Blackman's
father who's a professor at Berkeley is
now right Nancy know where
he works with GTE Sylvania okay he's a
piece of he's a paper writer in the Bay
Area yes Nelson Blackman and and he he
caught me on the very you know hand out
number two here where I said the above
proof actually commits another sin
against mathematical exposition and he
says it's better to say the proof above
actually commits another sin against
mathematical exposition yeah peccavi I I
was certainly sinning here myself and I
and I find that I do this rather often
and a reason must be because I I don't
find it unusual construction on the
other hand right so I don't quite agree
with all of his comments had put in the
Martin we said above below afraid alone
beneath the head underneath are among
the adjectives that never proceed the
nouns they modify but but but go after
well now I don't do those all as
adjectives but i was using one as it as
a above proof so i was using this an
adjective there although it's really
it's a preposition and you'd say the
proof above then you're sort of using it
as a preposition with it that that whose
object isn't implied i guess i'm a i'm
not a scholar on these things but below
I don't know if I would call it an
adjective if I said the proof below
whatever above and below are however
different we say all of the above none
of the above it's a it's a common phrase
that we are we now understand and it
just happens that above has its as one
of those meetings and it's because it's
because above and below or are parallel
in some places doesn't mean that they
that all of their meanings are going to
be parallel to each other still this
would definitely be an improvement to
put the put the above second the word
above second there II circle ie here and
I supposedly just meant that that was a
stylistic laps to go into into Latin
informal
ism I don't know he wanted me to wanted
me to you the semicolon there because he
felt that you needed more of a more time
to read the to read the rest of the
sentence or something the proof was
going too fast for your comprehension
otherwise it's a matter of pacing it so
that you can best judge when your second
reading but the main the main thing I
get from this is that I'm reminded that
the style has to be your own and you
won't get and there are going to be a
lot of places where you're just going to
have to agree to disagree that there is
no what some people would never write
other people would would would always
right and would think what's better and
this is this especially at this time of
year I remember this reminded of this
because my wife and I compose a
newsletter every year telling the story
of that year for our friends and
relatives and so on and many years ago
we we realized that the only way to
solve this problem was that that she
would write a paragraph and then I would
write a paragraph there was no way that
we could both write a sentence that we
would both think was the right was a
good sentence and we you know you know
we we seem to get along 364 days of the
year except for the day that we tried to
write a joint Christmas newsletter there
were just no way to make the two styles
merd but with the separate paragraphs
that works rather well and even we were
even can say did you wouldn't it be
better to put a comma in the other
person's paragraph and sometimes we
accept that as a valid improvement still
there is definitely a lot of variety and
vive la différence now Nancy your father
didn't like the way I felt him I want to
make a comment you know Jimmy and
Rosalynn Carter wrote a book together
here it's on and oh there you are live
yeah and and that was the comment that
they that they've made that they can do
everything else together in their life
except they can't seem to write together
and it was the worst experience either
of them had ever been through
oh ok yeah so I and I guess it would be
the same with a co-author if you had to
if you had to agree on every sentence of
every of every paragraph right now Aziz
while I didn't like the way we spelled
hiccups here at night and I and said
that this is the proper way to spell so
I look it up an addiction in the fist in
Rogge's and ro j didn't even have this
spelling had this spelling and then in
the other dictionary I had in my desk
this was the preferred spelling and they
said see also or also sometimes Bell
this way but ok let that was that caught
me by surprise ok now here's one for for
Paul to look at he cautioned us is this
right is this is this a bad thing to use
to use a noun as a verb i don't know but
there wasn't the comment here from some
mom Nancy's father but now here's
something I I don't understand me he
said so depending on the formula the
terms relation definition statement or
theorem might be used he wanted it to be
termed seems to me yeah I know but still
it I'm ready for for a list of terms but
I suppose you'd literally speaking if
you wanted to look at this from a
logical point of view then we're saying
that dumb you're supposed to do I don't
know there's the word or in there
doesn't seem to me that I have to use
more than one when it's a hyphenate
programming language let's talk about
programming language notation I'll look
for me I would be hyphenating words all
over the place if I did that because
because I'm not when I'm familiar with
it since it's in the field where
programming language is you know is it
commonly understood as as as a sort of a
sub-discipline by itself and wouldn't
need
but so the hyphen is sort of implied to
me I don't know make a comment yes well
when the associative law should worry
you this is a programming language
notation or a programming language
realization there's no there's
absolutely no confusion to a computer
scientist you see but to someone who who
isn't I can see where this would would
it happen to you go so I spoke once
about random number generators and and a
floating-point arithmetic and and and i
had a book about these things and I am I
had to take out all the hyphens
afterwards because it was just looking
terrible and you referring them all the
time ok well the see the next thing I
wanted to show is about hopefully I
guess no no well well like well I see it
here I got another another I got an
interesting note from Leslie Lamport who
are about proof by contradiction so we
should talk a little bit about that and
that he started out obviously in he
wants he wants to to rile us right away
he says I had to leave the tube just as
hell most was beginning to diatribe
against proof I don't you know by not
even I have never seen diatribe before
used as a verb but that's good in order
to you know in order to set I move now
well but but he's saying what about cut
proof by contradiction are they always
bad and I don't think we ever said that
they're always bad what we said was that
if that there's such a thing as an
unnecessary proof by contradiction which
and if you can do it directly I do so
but he's pointing out a case where weary
quare that in his work on on studying
concurrent programs that really
contradiction turned out to be the the
natural intuitive way to actually hook
to actually do it and so let me believe
state in fact that when you're solving a
problem
probably the most efficient way to go
about it is to is to try first the proof
by contradiction proof but I mean this
is this is sort of a so if I'm writing a
book and and then the writing of the
book is supposed to illustrate all the
all the things that I tossed around in
my mind is I was working on the problem
myself then the most honest presentation
would probably be to say well I first
tried proving by contradiction now why
is that it's because it gives me more
hypotheses I got more power more things
to derive from like I ever i can assume
the contradiction that gives me more
assumptions and therefore I you know
more my theorems come to play and then
at and so actually when I'm working on a
new problem probably a contradiction you
know I mean it's not just that I'm a
contrary person I think that I that that
I need to get my juices stirred up in
order to in order to say know it's wrong
but but in fact it gives you more it
gives you more to work with on you on
the other hand it does it actually can
can limit the applicability of this
theorem afterwards if you if you really
need to rely on the contradiction and it
also can be very confusing to to a
reader so it's this but there's this
tension that's all that happens I think
in all problem solving you the method
that you first try to solve something it
doesn't necessarily lead to the thing
that you want to present in your final
exposition of the of the solution so so
there will certainly be cases where
we're a proof by contradiction is to
that you know he doesn't he's not going
to exclude the middle the he's not going
to disallow he's not going to go like
intuition it's mathematics and say that
you're not ever allowed to to show that
something is true because it can't be
false and I i would i would hate to have
that weapon weapon removed 02 okay now
let's see another thing I wanted to show
you that shark is in the paper that I
was asked to referee recently and I just
want to show
a very common error when mathematicians
use tech they believe that that the best
way to write fractions is the way they
write them on a blackboard and I think
you can see here that this fraction
would be much nicer if it had been done
in the slashed form n squared / 3
instead of instead of in these tiny
numbers here like this and you see how
it how it how it interferes with the
litter look nope nope the people at
behind the scenes that journals have
been doing this for years mathematicians
give the manuscripts that have these
fractions done like this and then the
copier is know how to how to how to make
these changes and make make this thing
come out but now that people now
mathematicians are getting this in their
own hands and they're going to bypass
the copy editors in there they're gonna
and they're going to ruin everything if
they if they don't learn about those
some fractions about about when when
some fractions look better than okay
next was things about hopefully now how
we had this wonderful essay near the
beginning of the quarter I guess it's
handout number for that talks about
hopefully and mary claire i passed it
out more for the for the style of
writing of the essay then for the actual
semantics of it which also makes points
about about the word hopefully but i
just i just put it on as a sort of a
marvelous essay in general and it was an
exposition of a technical point as so as
an example of exposition is it and I is
a reason I handed this out now so Mary
Claire then sends me a note says
actually I now that you now that you
decided to put this to a wider audience
I reread it again and I thought it was
terrible and so she said so she
definitely has to change two things
about this essay to improve
it and I want and I think this is
interesting to see the before and after
because because I I started with this
and I thought it was with was very nice
but then she looked at it and she
thought oh this got to be fixed up and
and so the first so the first thing she
points out is she says look at given
that i'm going to need to say 1637 i
have to say something else instead of
late in the 16th century so here's her
go here she definitely knows that you
know looking ahead at what she's going
to have to say she's going to she wants
to give a citation we're the only
appropriate way to to to give it as the
given actual actual year 1637 but then
right in the beginning of a very opening
sentence dr. talk about late in the 16th
century and there's there's different so
that's a different way of giving dates
and if you clip if this is a big book
you're allowed to use different ways to
give days but if you're writing a 4
paragraph essay on something it's better
to to do something especially 16 the two
number 16 are our little I mean people
reading 16th century you know if they
think about a thing they'll know it's
it's really the 1500s but if it's but
still the 16 sticks in the in the head
more than than the semantics of the 15
so she would then change this to late in
the 15 late in the 1500s in order to be
consistent with her 1930s and 16th to n
on getting the other ones in there I
fight me then she says here's a sentence
she said impersonal substantives on the
other hand served less often than
personal ones at the head of the kind of
a covers we modify whatever of the
manner she says this sentence is so hard
I prefer to think I was drunk when I
wrote it to fix it I have to rewrite the
whole paragraph sliding adverb of manner
up earlier so she's talking about
something called an adverb of manner and
her point here is that there are
different kinds of adverbs and and so
she she rewrites the sentence as follows
this will be in the note
as remote adjectives both of these
hopefuls regularly produced hype and Lee
adverbs of manner the kind of
hopefulness that make means expected an
eager produced adverbs more readily than
the kind that means promising and bright
there's nothing mysterious about the
difference in frequency the patterns
such and such which he displays here is
very common a person can carry himself
hopefully auraiya desirable object
hopefully or prepare himself hopefully
for a possible future uses himself to
your community the pattern impersonal
now an active verb adverb of manner is
less common impersonal noun served less
often than personal ones nonetheless a
waiter can be shaping up hopefully a day
can begin hopefully and so on now this
is the so this is a rewrite of the
sentence that I think is worthwhile
looking at and somehow that that
paragraph I guess the sentence wasn't
wasn't great but I but since it was
embedded there in the middle it didn't
know I didn't you've got by me okay I
was willing to to accept anything by the
time I had such nice such a nice intro
into into the thing I got another
comment on hopefully from teacher in in
the English department at Stanford Rob
thoroughly I don't know aha well you see
you when you write something you never
know who you will be reaching so so now
I don't know if this person is male or
female but but so I can't refer to him
or her by and by a pronoun but I will
say this i will say that that Robin is
teaching a class next quarter English
191 a calc Mac called writing about
science and that's why I thought I would
get in communication and said that and
she commented about handout number four
she thought that the current prisoner so
hopefully was useful because she was
taught as a graduate student he was
thought whoever robbed installed always
to say something of positive about every
student paper is not always
this is somehow I shouldn't be putting
this on TV I'm sure neatly typed is
really to Petra nicing and often
inaccurate but I can almost always say
thank you for not abusing the word
hopefully since students avoid it like
the plague no question yes on that
proceeding paper I doors to go with the
parenthesis of formula formula as the
parole yes all right here yeah okay but
you're never if you're gonna message or
is that still used oh well well you see
I if you'll probably notice uh Paul uses
formula in his notes and Tracy is this
formulas in it but you know and so if I
if I thought it must be British spelling
and and I take any chance to use my AE
literature in fact I even write letters
to people in Phoenix Arizona just going
to use the OE Bob Floyd sent me comments
on hopefully she's really rich gets to
the point that I hope I remember to make
so first of all he says hopefully he
shows the American Heritage Dictionary
okay which is and she has a usage note
there's two versions of the American
Heritage Dictionary this one says the
use of hopefully to me it is to be hoped
as in hopefully we'll get there before
dark is grammatically justified by now
if you'd similar uses of happily and
mercifully however this usage is by now
such a bugbear to traditionalist that it
is best avoided on grounds of civility
if not lodge
okay and so Bob's comment on this is
American heritage is justified it by
analogy to happily mercifully I disagree
mercifully we'll get there before dark
equals it is merciful that we will get
there before dark not I am merciful that
will get there before dark hopefully
we'll get there before dark means I am
hopeful that we'll get there before he
so he doesn't see that they marry one of
the points of Marie Claire's essay which
he hadn't read at the time he sent me
this note was the that hopeful is is
used in both senses personal and
impersonal but but I think the point is
is that there are a lot of people whose
hackles get up just as it says here it's
a bugbear to a lot of people which means
that it's very so that it's very
problematical to our to decide whether
you're going to use it in writing as
Mary Clare said in her essay what should
we do ignore the ignorant bully boys or
knuckle under and that's what she's made
up made a point yet when Bob sent me
another note saying that there's an
unabridged american heritage dictionary
that has bet that noted that 44 / only
forty-four percent of the usage panel
will accept hopefully in the sense of it
is to be hoped so they have this
percentage you know how were in whatever
is man was roped who wrote to all of his
usage people and gave him a long
questionnaire about to 2000 2000 or just
mystery questions and they all voted on
it and then he reports the statistics in
this in and they're usually pretty
interesting so i think that's pretty
good forty four percent actually accept
it that's pretty that's pretty that's
pretty good but in fact fifty six
percent do not so it is a word that has
that has problems just on the basis of
you know that you're going to offend a
certain number of people even if you use
it probably absolutely correctly and so
it's a matter of that is the similar to
the rules with with quotation marks if
you want to if give if you want to
help make the revolution towards the
towards the improvement and consider
that Marvel wrist and than irritating
some some of the readers distracting
them away from the point you're trying
to make for them then you should you
should by all means of push on yeah oh
this is what I was just going to get to
and and I was and never seen other
things that I've sent to me saying that
yes our friend here from Austria knows
that the whole foot lift is a very good
German word and and in fact it has
exactly the right meaning that everybody
who misuses hopefully in America wishes
that they had a word for and this is the
the function is needed and yeah it is
it's used much more than the hook will
enjoy a meeting yes yes it's a get out
of its cultural spoiled Oh offers but
opens for okay so it's it's and so so
there's there yeah so a couple of the
things that that I got here talked about
talked about hoffentlich and and and
certainly fills a need in fact there are
many there are many other as you the
more you write the more you realize that
there are words that just don't exist in
English that we that we really have a
need for and in technical writing the
ones that I miss most often are verbs
that that implies that you're losing
something instead of winning something I
mean now we have all kind we have we
have our sports writers will have
hundred ways to describe the fact that
that that team a B team B they they
bested them they murdered them etc etc
they clobbered them now how many is it
for the opposite what can you say that
that be did to a when be lost again
there isn't such a thing you have to say
it in two or three words and but a
mathematical writing you'd like to have
the ability to have these words and we
don't we don't always
we often now missing missing them now
let's see well I don't this is I can't
find what is this burn steiner somebody
who had talked about hopefully and aunt
oftenly but some of the comments that
that that Bob sent me were obviously
from the people that Mary Claire was
reading where she got upset about the
the people who really didn't know what
they were talking about because some of
the some of the comments that that have
been having been said about it our are
pretty pretty off the off the mark still
it's a matter of how risk how much you
want to risk of offending the
sensibilities of certain of certain
readers as opposed to you know you can
maybe get their goodwill by by other
things that you say and and so it can be
important okay now the next thing Bob i
quoted bob flight about exclamation
points and he said he fear you
misunderstood my attitude on exclamation
points there correct after interjections
like ouch after census there
exclamations like don't you dare when
exclaimed or shouted and that's why
they're called exclamation points in
informal writing an author may be
forgiven a few bangs on census one can
imagine his exclamations but a long
sentence goes under the category
exclamations we doubt ever God exclaimed
okay now um so and then he showed me he
showed me excerpts of dictionaries where
they give a definition of ! and it all
it says something that follows an
exclamation now that surprised me
because I mean that surprise me !
because nobody in the references that i
saw seem to ever suggest that ! is ever
used to convey surprise isn't that true
though that sometimes you can that i
mean is this only in children's stories
i think that that this happened that you
say the bed was empty or something
but you know that's not nobody was
explaining it but it was or something
Paul what do you think there is a
writing device that works very well in
that very context to put an exclamation
put parenthesis ! close parenthesis
after a sentence for which you want to
express surprise or an eyebrow raised oh
okay I do it doesn't violate the rule
that you are walking and at the same
time makes the very point you want to
make yeah that's a good that's a good
thought right ok let's see bob bob says
advice to always avoid splitting
infinitives is unwise and and and he
sends me several references about that
and and that's true that almost
everybody says it the split infinitive
is sometimes just the right thing to do
but because it puts the act when it when
it puts the accent in the right way but
they but the bad examples tend to be
where where the where and I'm splitting
the infinitive gives an obvious
obviously improved sentence the good
examples are the ones where we're moving
the ad the adverb around make the
sentence seem very forest so it's a
matter of ear there he says about
prepositions at the end of sentences any
gives some some references I says you
have no case give up and he ends it with
up of course but I i looked at the i
looked at the things and i totally agree
i have no case i mean i coming from
Milwaukee Wisconsin where half the
population is is German and is used to
putting the the first part of a the
preposition part of a verb at the end of
their senses I probably overreacted to
this and there but but English teachers
do do say this
miss what is her name miss thorne with
Jordan was a wofford this is the
prototypical English teacher that's that
people talk about it says she would she
would give you know he might miss with
Miss thistle bottom there she is up with
which I will not put and so talks about
the the main idea is that the
preposition provides strength at the end
of the sentence and and and a bad
example is he felt it offer the best
opportunity to do fundamental research
in chemistry which was what he had taken
his doctor philosophy degree in and he
says the end of a sentence is a
conspicuous point can be a strong point
the end of the sense just quoted like
the last letter of an engine going deaf
that's the so that's the I think about
preposition okay okay let's see he shows
me Strunk and white about the word about
using that strong said something about
John where are we here extermination
points in line well they think he gave
an example said something like he said
he was going in as being better than he
said that he was going and I agree but
it but you have the chance that you but
you can parse it immediately because you
know the word he is there in this in the
innocence because if it's a pronoun and
so it has a different form as it would
in another part of a sentence so you
don't so the word that is is not needed
as a grammatical help to tell you what's
coming up but but in when we're doing
technical writing we're not usually
talking about pronouns like this but we
usually are in a situation where there's
some now and where we would we wouldn't
know what the we wouldn't know exactly
what what parts of speech were looking
at as we're coming into it so i found
that often i put in the word that just
in order to be a sort of silent helper
and
22 departs it now the final thing I
wanted to discuss is a very interesting
note i got from dan Schroeder hear about
which verses that I know you've heard
all you thought you've heard everything
about which verses that already but I
would like to say the final truth about
that subject if I can only find my
advanced comment here I got to try to
get it on my question why you're looking
yahoo can answer it hey what about if
then didn't you say at some point early
in the quarter that you would always
have it then if you had an if class at
all then well what do you think I don't
know if you don't know when the
chronicle got up and said what are all
these dead junior looks like programming
like well she's I just saw the norton
and it said that she had a sentence with
many them's in it one sentence with four
or five them's in it which which could
could perhaps be broken broken into
however I I think there's a difference
between newspaper writing and writing
about mathematics in in some cases where
you were we talking about implications
of comments okay ah here we go good so I
again it's something that my wife and I
may not agree on but but when I when I
read something at speed and I find that
I don't understand that I've now getting
to the conclusion but if I put the word
then in I would understand that then I
think they're it helps and and this ties
in with the point I want to make now is
that I I believe when we when we are
reading something at speed 4x4
comprehension our main
are we are using a part of our brain
that's only doing simple parsing and not
doing complicated logical reasoning as
to how as good as to what should be done
now I mean it's simple enough that it
can be done in a few cycles of our very
slow a computer inside of our heads and
therefore well let me show you the the
point at issue now no I I changed which
to that in five places of dance term
paper when he turned it in and he
thought that he would he said they must
emphasize on all five of these senses I
used which only after carefully
considering whether that would be
preferable i have now considered each of
them even more carefully and concluded
that blindly changing wish to that would
be appropriate and at most one of the
sentences so he willing to give me a
less than or equal twenty percent on it
now let me explain my reasoning and like
the one of the main points i want to try
to make is that maybe reasoning is not
the thing involved here that it's
something it's something that goes by
too fast in your head to even care about
reasoning it's a matter of what syntax
more than semantics and the the sixth
sentence that issue is the second one
here our discussion will contain many
gaps which this approach from the bottom
up cannot fill and he and his comment is
about sentence to saying that here i see
no way to use that without implying that
there are also gaps that this approach
can't be that this coach can fill and
there aren't in other words he's saying
that you that if that since the since
the word that is supposed to be used in
a restrictive manner you're not supposed
to talk about the a that be unless there
also exists some a that for which not be
is true
and my my line I I don't know if I own
agree i think that i think that the here
we have a case where where we have a
grammatical construction where it's one
way of attaching an attribute to a is
saying you're saying v is also true
about a now it now it's a strong way of
doing it because it's it goes in in a
hurry and we're talking about the a that
be but now but i don't believe that
whenever you read a sentence that has
the word that in it you also stop and
say now he's implying that this is
restrict that this is restrictive that
that I'm now getting an assertion from
the author that a gap could could fill
some some other approach something like
this so I asked Mary quite specifically
about this and she agreed that the word
that would be preferable here yeah it's
not they're not certainly no objection
to it might but the point is if you have
to go back and rethink and use logic on
a sentence then then it's not the kind
of the way the way it seems to me where
my my my brain is going along reading it
just parsing it for for for meaning I
this which catches me as a as something
where there was a missing car life is
going to be a wish or without thinking
about it but if I if I have a gap here I
mean I five of that here I would just
attach the this as a clause on and I
wouldn't really worry a great deal as to
how restrictive it's being in the world
with that point about an a that be the
better be na that not be sounds to me
like a step in the direction of the
sastras possibility of making the silly
syntactical correctness undecidable that
is it depends on the content of the
paragraph and yeah a lot of people do
make recommendations that amount to that
when you analyze me yeah so so
I I think that if you have to go to a
long dissertation about about the logic
of it and then it's missing the point of
the way we actually read that's my my
long dissertation on that subject now
but uh question would it be okay just to
put the comment and make that a
non-restrictive clause because we are
saying again we say that like all the
gaps oh yeah well we've got various
approaches here now but they but anyway
dance dance rewrite is much better he
just besides to tear up all things
they're all of course it's intuitive
bottom-up approach will contain many
gaps when you run into a problem usually
the best way is to just is to just
finesse it go you know and Mary Claire
would would prefer saying bottom up with
a hyphen set of in quotes here and it's
it's a matter of taste to try and see
there whether you want to apologize for
using bottom-up Tom you know physics
book all right now summarize something
there i mean i think in every one of
those five sentences there was a problem
with the sentence and on one hand i did
think that changing which to that was
not the solution nevertheless the fact
that there was possibly Wicked Witch
pointed to other problems and yeah like
you say it you have to think that long
about a sentence something wrong with in
the first place I yeah but but but
there's an automatic parsing provided by
that which is mostly a coupling of a
noun to a property that I don't think if
you just want to couple it down to a
property quickly you can do it that was
better with that and then with witches
now there was a very amusing case of
left to right reading in the in Marie
Claire's comment on another another
point then says even if course and
punctuation were a problem the author is
mistaken about where the witch Clause
ends you get this I was expecting the
next word to be judgment or opinion or
something the authors muster you know so
the
but she's talking about that that was
that was uninteresting now so you have
to look for the sentences to be able to
understand as you where you are what not
be surprised by who about when it occurs
if you need especially it occurs at the
end of a line of course and and I see
I'm a little bit over time Thank You
Tracy but I got to show you this there's
something about coincident punctuation
here which hadn't been brought up
earlier in the course so we said
coincident commas are not as I on bad
punctuation any more than the
coincidence of a final common a period
or a final comment and a semicolon or
any two marks of punctuation we r 2
comments coincide we write only one
she's talking about where where you
would have a sentence where each there's
2 reasons have a comma in one place and
so there's no point so when a comment a
period could say we write the period etc
this is where appeared in a period
coincide obviously you see I thought
that was nice nice example there ok I
have gotten to the end of my list and I
want to thank you all for enduring this
this quarter and I look forward to
reading your term papers before 5pm next
week that Wednesday sharp pacific
standard time no well having them in my
possession